Robert Leckie and your lifetime how many
books have you written about 40 when did
you start when I was 16
I love football I wanted to play
football my father wouldn't let me and
now I have a theory that the knock of
opportunity is a hard rap because not
being allowed to play football although
I played basketball on a state
championship team I began to cover it
that was the beginning of my career
after 40 bucks
how come a book on Okinawa well for one
reason my friend al Silverman the editor
is an old friend of mine and he wanted a
book on Okinawa and he wanted it this
size and I gave it to him and I think
that that is one of the assets of this
book he said it's short as compressed
what was Okinawa Okinawa was most sought
after by both sides for the reason that
the Japanese did not know that we were
making an atomic weapon and then we had
not yet made it workable we wanted it
for a staging area with 60 miles long 18
miles wide its widest 2 miles
narrow as Narrows it could have been a
base but dozens of airfields two huge
Anchorage's in Russia and one which was
later called Buckner Bay and it was only
375 miles from Kyushu the southernmost
island of Japan Japan wanted to destroy
the American invaders and so Admiral
Onishi who was off in the Battle of the
Philippine Sea he was the first one to
come up with the idea of the kamikaze
now kamikaze means divine with us I'm
sure you know but at the end of the 13th
century Kubla Kahn the Mongol Emperor of
China grandson of the great Genghis Khan
assembled to invasion please to concrete
your parent both times ten years apart
both times
typhoon Rose scattered and Psyche the
fleets so the Japanese call it kamikaze
meaning divine wind and it was a gift
from the Sun God from whom the Imperial
Japanese family is supposed to have
descended but anyway with this new
weapon and a hundred and ten thousand
men under lieutenant-general Russia Jima
the thirty second Japanese army and
especially with the kamikaze they were
going to destroy the US Navy so they
could come no closer to Japan and so
they began what was called the Special
Attack Corps and these were young boys
many of them brave and dedicated they
knew nothing about flying they flew old
decrepit crates from which even the
instruments had been stripped down which
there were no guns all they had was the
bomb they learned enough to fly to their
target led by the conventional fighter
planes they didn't expect them to learn
how to return because they weren't
supposed to return well the one of the
troubles with the Japanese character is
that failure of any kind especially fade
in in a battle or in a war is expiated
only by taking your own life and
especially any failure concerning the
enemy so that let's go back to I am
you know the big naval battle in June
June 6
when Yamamoto attacked what was going to
you know the Midway Midway anyway
alright
they lost three carriers at Midway and
so carrier power in the Pacific returned
to equity for American for Japanese but
when it began it was for Japanese and in
sent one American you know okay
so on the return journey Yamamoto locked
himself in his cabin and never came out
and the word Midway was never uttered
again in the Japanese Navy Imperial
General Howe Tech was men in the army
knew about it Hirohito knew that there
had been a great defeat but neither of
them knew the details you see so that
these young boys and this army there I'm
going to go back to what now where I was
I wish may I just ask you what service
were you Marie
where's marine division and when did you
go on the service Pearl Harbor Day but
the man said to me the doctor now you
may want to edit this out I don't know
but else I'll say it he said I'm going
to accept you he said because you're a
fine physical specimen except for one
thing I said what's that he said you'll
have to get circumcised first I said
circumcised what do you think I'm gonna
do to the enemy so he said you know
something he said I know you're going to
come back and I did but at least I had
Christmas at home and I went to Parris
Island January 5th all right on December
7th 1941 Pearl Harbor day you were how
old
not quite 21 so I waited until I was 21
which was December 18th and where did
you live then Rutherford New Jersey
right the Meadowlands and the big Sports
Complex and by that time you had had
five years of writing well then he was
16 yeah yeah five years right
and what did you written at that point
in your head I was a sports writer and
then I became a feature writer and a
rewrite man did you record those you
have college
I know only after the law even then I
never liked the classroom I never liked
the classroom I despised the classroom
mind so when you went into the Marine
Corps you really bring a lot you were
you were a child kid I made private four
times I won't discuss the occasions but
I was a wild kid the last time they gave
me a PFC stripe they said now don't
Louis lose at this time I said then why
did you put a zipper on uh-huh so you
know Smedley Butler said give me a
regiment of big rats and all little big
bats so you went in the day where the
month after Pearl Harbor in January of
1942 right when did you go Jared see
battle oh no no no we were all very
green we were the most high hearted kids
you've ever seen mostly we were officer
material
it's a shame that they took them all so
early you want to sit with me
and you know I had never been in battle
I went to Parris Island and at that time
the course was shortened from 12 weeks
to six weeks and we left in May for the
west coast and we went by Pullman train
because my regiment the first regiment
and the other regiment the 5th regiment
the 5th regiment went by sea and was
nearly sunk by the submarines thereafter
they took us across the country it was a
wonderful experience but once you got
into the Marine Corps did you go into
battle oh we went to battle August 7
1942 we landed on Guadalcanal and what I
was trying to tell you about Laurel
canal is another failure in the Japanese
character in that of course they kind of
report defeat do you see now the first
attack I was in that battle the Battle
of a general August 7th 1942 it was on
the general River and what was called
the ichiki detachment was me a cracked
detachment about 2,200 men or more they
attacked my battalion the night of
August 20 21st we killed them all we
lost 26 they don't remember those things
we lost 26 we killed 2200 and you know
what the commanding general reported to
Tokyo the attack of the ichiki
detachment was not
entirely successful so that's a
crippling defect and it existed to all
the high command and you were a private
the Marine Corps yes but you say
somewhere early in this book that you
thought you were going to fight by day
and right by night in this money yes yes
it's very funny my typewriter was in the
the George F Elliot an African slaver if
it was anything else they wouldn't even
let us paint the thing because if we
chipped the sides they were played the
price would fall off that's in San
Francisco Bay but anyway it was sunk
when I light it now I'm not trying to
pretend it was a bullet I wasn't we were
all sure but a zero crashed the Med ship
I don't know whether he was the first
kamikaze or not but anyway my typewriter
was a bullet and it sank and I came home
in the girl next door I saw her I fell
in love it I married him and I'll tell
you why she had a royal typewriter just
the same as mine and that's when you
came back after the work yeah early on
and this your book this on the Okinawa
on page 54 okay you have about a page in
which you've set the scene for what it
was like August 7 1942 yes and it's got
so much in it can you open it up to that
page and read that to read the whole
thing so we can get a sense of what it
was like this when did you write this I
wrote this when I wrote a book called
strong men on was published by Random
House in 1962 it was US Marines against
Japan and I described Guadalcanal and in
this book what the jungle islands were
like in which all the Americans who
fought in them would realize where is
Guadalcanal located in relationship to
Japan well Guadalcanal was quite far
from Japan it's nothing like a vote 750
miles from Japan okay now at 350 I don't
know know how many thousand miles but
it's in the the farthest of the Solomon
Islands and they're quite away they're
closer to Australia than they are to
Japan so you remember what age you were
when you wrote this book Oh probably
just before I went free know how to say
about twenty-eight thirty something like
that years old
yeah so this was about seven or eight
years after what you're about to read us
with seven errors after you gotten to I
after I published my first poking oh
he's reading Guadalcanal
she was beautiful seen from the sea this
slender Long Island her towering central
mountains ran down her spine in a great
graceful east/west keel the Sun seemed
to kiss her Timberline and lay
shimmering on open patches of tan grass
dabbling the green of her forests gentle
waves washed her beaches white raising a
glitter of Sun and water and scoured
sand beneath fringing groves of coconut
trees leading languorous Lisi wood with
knotty
star-shaped heads she was beautiful but
beneath her loveliness within the
necklace of sand and palm under the
coffee of her sunkissed treetops with
its tiara of jeweled birds she was a
mass of slops and stinks and Testaments
of scum crested legumes and bile swamps
inhabited by giant crocodiles the place
of spiders as big as your fist and wasps
as long as your finger of lizards the
length of your leg or his brief is your
thumb of ants that bit like fire of tree
leases that for fastening suck of
scorpions without the guts to kill
themselves a centipede whose foul
scurrying of course human skin leaves a
track of inflamed flesh of snakes that
slither and land crabs that scuttled and
of rats and bats and carrion birds and
of a myriad of stinging insects by day
black swarms of flies feed on open cuts
and make the molars by night mosquitoes
come in cloud bringing malaria dengue or
when he one of a dozen filthy exotic
fevers night or day the rains come and
when it is a monster it comes in
torrents conferring a moist mushrooming
life on all that tangled green of Vine
fern creeper and Bush dripping on
eternally in the rain forest
nourishing kingly hardwoods so
abundantly that they saw more than a
hundred feet into the air
rotting them so thoroughly at their base
that a rare wind or perhaps only a man
leaning against them will bring them
crashing down and Guadalcanal stack
she was sour with the odor of her own
decay a breath so hot and humid so
sullen and so still that all those
hundreds of thousands of Americans who
came to her during the ensuing three
years of war cursed and swore to feel
the vitality losing from them in a
steady stream of enervating sweat did
you get malaria oh yes did you ask you I
was married No
if you had malaria nine times that I had
dengue which is much worse than I got
that in the hospital tangy
it's called breakbone fever it says as
all your bones are in a vise and someone
is turning the vise you can't even take
water your spleen becomes distended you
do nothing but vomit bile so they have
to if you were in the jungle you'd
certainly die but they had to feed you
intravenously and maybe it's what just
as well that I got into the hospital but
he had the malaria doesn't compare to it
how long were you over in the Pacific
Theater almost three years were you you
in Okinawa no I wasn't thank God
why because next to evil and Peleliu
that was us shut for shut step by step
battle chiefly because the Japanese had
changed the top tactics now from
Guadalcanal and out to the jungle
islands and so on the Japanese military
doctrine was destruction of the enemy at
the water's edge and the tactic they
used was what we called the band's eye
choice with at night they always
attacked at night no matter where even
with the new tactics to negate our great
superiority in artillery and in naval
gunfire so they were attacking night and
sometimes if they were near
homeland or in a base like one which was
a Japanese liquor locker sometimes they
would drop and they would come and they
would come banging their bayonets in a
Cantonese screaming what they thought
were bloodthirsty oaths a Japanese boy
eat American boys blood u.s. Malayan
you'll be dead tomorrow
what a lot of nonsense because today
they were shocked by the obscenity that
greeted them because nobody can swear as
you may know like US Marines and so that
was the battle tactic and it always
broke their back ok now the battle
Okinawa happened what date at the at the
end the first time it was discovered was
in the Battle of vehicle off the coast
of the Gennie's it was a very good
commander there he didn't want anymore
but they caught the good Japanese
commanders called bamboo spear tactics
so he invented the tactic of delay
defense in depth what was simply in a
ambush so he made a monster steel cheese
of the air force of the airfield there
was the object and his army regiment
practically stroll into it because
there's been no resistance but when they
hit the airfield there were pins of the
ground and it could only be withdrawn at
night by Amtrak's pulling him up to the
bottom now that tactic was repeated
again in much greater depth at Peleliu I
was a peloton I got that was the end of
combat for me 10:7 and they had the same
thing only parallel was a you a drowned
mountain heaved above the sea coral what
was the date on Peleliu September 10th
1944 yeah I know can I was in April 1st
1945 yes right and that tactic was
developed and used again on evil it's
February of 1945 and brought to a
fruition and perfection on Okinawa
because Russia Jima wisely decided not
to resist at the water's edge the
Japanese general yes right he was
commander of the Japanese 32nd army
110,000 men he decided not to defend at
the water's edge and the greatest naval
bombardment in
history fell harmlessly under Higuchi be
she's the only person was hurt in the
invasion was a Marine who shot his
fingers and it was the so then the
Marines went up north and they hadn't
with troubled terrain but it was lightly
defended and the army 24th Corps for our
divisions and there were three marine
divisions with one was the second was on
floating reserve of the southern
bleachers once they turned right the
army they came into the worst kind of
party these were east-west ridges what
is called crosshatch fighting there are
no passes shallow plain open plains
shallow rivers and so on nothing but
Carl east-west from the East China Sea
to the Pacific Ocean let me ask you
before we get into the Okinawa battle
itself about your career and you say
you've written some 40 books a and in
the beginning of your book they're
listed history autobiography Belle
lettre fiction and then for younger
readers hey have you made a living off
of writing books yeah I still can drink
first growth wise that's one of the
purposes you know which book that you've
sold I sold the most you know this one
which is the smallest might have but I
think I maybe helmet for my pillow
might've because my god had 15 different
jackets and was printed all over the
world and it was anthologized all over
the world the war was a helmet for my
poem it was my own experiences a
narrative came out in 1957 September
1957 and I would think this is it
delivered from evil which is the saga
world war two is still in print and that
came out in 86 I think the Wars of
America has been updated three times and
and that's sixteen oh nine to nineteen
ninety one and this one I am astonished
at the exposure and the response why
because people are writing to me calling
me
up putting me on shows like this I've
been on these shows before but not so
often and I think it's because these
people who have fought are not Okinawa
really for a terrific battle especially
the sailors on picket duty you know with
the kamikaze how many American soldiers
and Marines and Army and Navy were
involved in Okinawa oh the biggest seven
five hundred five hundred and forty five
thousand but the most incredible feat is
this at so-called d-day Normandy I
didn't have anything approaching that
number he had absolute Arab superiority
though and he had some 4300 crear but
those were not all ocean-going ships by
any means and he only had 20 miles to
cover but the Americans don't forget in
the Allied forces that were British and
the word poles and there were Free
French and renegade Italians and so on
our solving force was a hundred and
eighty thousand Ike's was a hundred and
fifty thousand but as a feat of naval
skill most of these ships
sortied from Seattle and San Francisco
going almost 8,000 miles to the battle
and they all got there on the appointed
day that is a feat of seamanship never
equals and the reason for this is it too
you know prior to 1950 we were all in a
sense not 1950 prior to the war we were
all in the sense just place your
appearance not like we are now and the
focus on Europe is understandable
because of that and also because of the
very attractive personality like I would
not say that the MacArthur's duplicated
that in any way you always wanted to ask
him what he did on the seventh day and
yes you say I got wrote this down you at
one time you've referred to the typical
McCarthy an
selfishness oh yes you did you get a
sense when you read your book you didn't
like him I admired him at first I
invited him at first when I joined the
Marines and so on and so forth but as I
said he would see no other Sun in the
heavens when he was approached by the
first president of the Philippines and
asked you know after he had resigned
after his second tour and unheard of it
wasn't actually completed but he never
before accepted more time and it's chief
of staff been asked to have a second
tour he was asked by Marcos he was asked
by the president of numbers and Marcos
he's asked by the President of the
Philippines if he thought the
Philippines were defensible and then
what he said he was about to retire
he said do I think it defensively he
said I think it's more than I think it's
any business that's ridiculous
surrounded by a sewer lagoons and
everything absolutely everywhere
vulnerable to invasion from the sea and
so he became the marshal of the
Philippines and then he but he didn't
had the money he developed a fleet of
mosquito boats formas keel boats can't
fight on the open ocean and the high
seas they sink we do just that just not
that the disability and he was oh it
would never fall in with anyone else's
plan or anything else like the so-called
orange plan under which the US Navy and
holding force was the Jolla Phillip
Phillip the Philippines while the US
Navy rush rescue Eisenhower Ike
authorized and knew that plan but when
he went to the Philippines he scuttled
it and and when the Admiral Nimitz I can
go on and on but I'm not going to but
but when I had mom Nemus generously
loaned him the 11th fleet which was to
be returned for Okinawa I don't know if
it was the 11th I'm not sure but any I
think was the limit but when he was
asked to return to succor though the
thirty-eight test 438 off Okinawa he
deliberately committed it to a useless
campaign let me ask you about your
technique on this book there are no
notes in the back there no bibliography
no there's no they're from footnotes but
they don't refer to any reference that's
what my others are wanted all the other
books a footnoted no not most of the
other books in the beginning with
footnoted and with a bibliography and
everything as you're supposed to do but
this hasn't no bibliography no foot he
didn't want it and it's selling better
maybe that's telling me something why is
it well I would imagine that you would
ma'am
I don't know but I would imagine that
the ordinary reader is more satisfied
with the horrible and doesn't and think
that the footnotes and the bibliography
is are pedantic and boring and they
don't like it
on that note let's go to the very end of
the book when you talk about the
generals committing oh yeah Harry Caray
oh yes oh you mean the sushi Jima and
Cho yeah these are the two leaders on
Okinawa for the Japanese right Cho was
equal of an axe exact opposite named
Yahaira very calm and carefully
considered in scientific Cho was the
founder of the cherry Society was he was
even considering
assassinating Hirohito but let me ask
you about definitions because you
mentioned earlier what's a samurai
samurai yes that was a professional
soldier trained in the days of the
Shogun's who were the real rulers of
japan and they seized they were the sons
of middle-class professional soldiers
and they were trained to know neither
joy nor pain and they were to serve the
Shogun to the end and the badge of the
rank was a two-handed saber we call the
samurai sword but that's the modified
one after the new warlords took charge
in China about right after work
Japan way about the time of World War
one and they had the right to kill
anyone
doing something different and they were
the shock truth in the sense and they
had very particular style of headdress
you enrolled it so much but at the end
I'm jumping to the end because I want
you to be interested to know how you
know all this you know they're little
the details on the sheet and all that
that when they decide to kill himself
yes and they lost yeah and they went the
two of them means it's the way all yes
hi Japanese Jenny they had a yogya they
had a piece and the authority for this
is the cook I forget his name
probably in a footnote and and they just
in their ceremonial robes and they had
the word he wrote cure it means stomach
cutting and they had a ceremonial knife
we say here I mean the Americans is
Harry Caray it was a term Harry Caray I
mean that's the first American carry and
it changed so often but seems to come
out finally is here a cure I'm not even
sure that but anyway they were prepared
and they had a year like almost like a
prayer rug of a Muslim they were dressed
in white they made the serial bow to the
emperor they sat down cross their legs
before they had a dinner of the Muslim
magnificent pools left it wasn't much a
lot of talking but canned foods and so
on and so forth and now the man thrusts
the knife into his stomach and turns and
if the pain becomes exquisite so that he
will faint someone is always standing
behind him either with a revolver or
samurai sword either the cut off his
head severed spinal column or put one
through his brain and that's what
usually happened because how often
during the war did the Japanese general
all the time oh listen Hollister all the
time I even had a friend whom in news in
there when I lived in Mountain Lakes New
Jersey was a had been a Marine he had
what he thought were really the horns of
a you know that legendary beast the
single horn
nor Unicoi and he actually did that of
course he found me drunk and they also
probably some of them will probably join
they were great drinkers a Japanese how
many Americans were killed on Okinawa
12,500 a casualty I have the catch Li
Jie's right here exactly on both sides
okay let's see
roughly how many Japanese died well a
hundred thousand were killed and
strangely enough what a a much MacColl
10,000 surrendered that was unusual I
was a phenomenon you even have a picture
in here of yes yes of the Japanese being
guarded by only one American soldier
yeah roughly hundred thousand hundred
thousand dead surprisingly another
10,000 captured American casualties
total 49,000 151 marine losses at 29 38
dead or missing in 13 708 wounded the
army at 4,000 675 and 18 Oh 99 in the
Navy's forty nine oh seven and forty
eight 24 there was a little left of
Japanese air power losses of between
3,000 and 4,000 planes allows 1900
kamikaze and a kamikaze again you talked
about being a young man that Joss could
fly to get to this to get to her and was
committed to commit suicide well in
Japan
it seems that any failure has to be
something has to put in a failure has to
be propitiated by the failure of the
failure and for them to have flocked to
this thing in the beginning is not
surprising but after that towards the
end they had a lot of return that means
a lot of them knew out of return and I
even wrote an introduction to a book
called I was a kamikaze well when when
you were in Guadalcanal the three years
you're over there in the Pacific did you
see yourself kamikazes diving on
oh no the capital of the Philippines and
then Okinawa because all the other
battles in
so my kamikazes came at the end that's
right that's right
and what the sailors went under undoing
oh they were on what was called a radar
picket line of all destroyers and they
were in a circle around Okinawa and
their mission was to give warning of the
approach to the enemy aircraft not only
the the kamikaze but the conventional
fighter aircraft zeroes the Daiya dive
bombers and the two engine Betty bombers
but there were the prime targets of the
kamikaze and so it you know then it was
awful I mean they did was scourge
hundred kamikaze in the baka bomb which
was called a foolish bomb because it was
piloted by a man that's hurt nobody and
it was faster than a bullet so it
couldn't be seen but it never worked at
the end of your book yet you get into
this controversy over whether or not the
bomb should have been up why did you
decide to get into it I didn't decide to
get into it because I've been trying to
tell the truth for forty years and I
went on a program last night and
everybody's insisting that the atomic
bombs we only had two it uh compelled
Japan to surrender but I trust Harry
Truman any time anything I'm sorry I
don't care what estimate said I love
that guy because he had true raw courage
and I was on a program inside in
somebody question means when I said that
Harry Truman had formed what was called
the US strategic bombing survey to
assess the effects of Allied bombing in
World War two and this man said lo
Roosevelt started that but I don't know
how he could have started it because he
died April 6 I think but something like
that and the Germans and surrendered to
him made it was no way we could have
assessed the effects I like mommy he may
put it I put it in motion but it was
Truman who really did it anyway this
survey declare based on a detailed
investigation of surviving Japanese
leaders and
all it is a surveys opinion that's
certainly prior to 31st December 1945
and in all probability prior to 1st
November 1945 Japan would have
surrendered even if the atomic bombs had
not been dropped
even if Russia had not entered the war
even if no invasion had been planned or
contemplated unquote I mean no judgment
could be more unequivocal you quote a
letter that Harry Truman wrote to his
sister in which he said it was a
terrible decision well yeah I know that
where did you get the letter I mean
that's the letter you quoted in your
book well I have his memoirs and when
did he write that to his sister do you
remember after he made the decision
after he was no longer president and
what he said it was a terrible decision
did he mean it was a bad decision
no nobody meant it was a terrible a
heart-rending but I mean four things
that this enemy did you do I mean what
do you think they would have done if
they had atomic weapons I mean it's like
have you ever played handball yeah well
you know some guys who color hollering
hinder well the answer to that I played
with the world champions I'm not nearly
as good as Pat Kirby hey so um one time
you turn it on the guy said what would
you have said if you had Koons of all
know anything now where do you live now
I live in Byram Township New Jersey uh
in the boondocks what do you think of
all this writing you've done I mean has
it been fun well I think I've made a
contribution and I'm pleased with it and
I intend to continue life that's the
great thing about mental skills if you
have them as opposed to physical skills
Mel's skills improve unless you get
Alzheimer's or something like that oh
you drink too much or whatever but
physical spill skills after some of the
years begin to deteriorate
how big a family dear my three I was the
youngest of eight them and how old are
you how old is your family well boys
girls oh yeah two boys and a girl my
brother Jeff is one of the finest
artists and
America like son jet the oldest boy
sounds like Alzheimer's doesn't its old
age and he just finished decorating the
castle in Limerick of the famous
financier Peter Lynch and he's done very
well he's about 44 very handsome unlike
his father what about your other two
kids uh John is a bassist be as a
teacher of high school teacher in
Spanish she goes to Spain almost and
every year
she's a fluent speaker native speaker
and David is running and buying out his
children the handball racquetball health
club that my wife and I opened 26 years
ago and he's buying his brother and
sister out so you ran a your own
handball court hole yeah that's what you
did besides write book yeah I did it I
had a t-shirt made and on the back of it
and said we died in shape and then
people would say well you play handball
you shrink
I suppose you know I play amble so I can
continue to dissipate what do you think
you know now when you write how do you
do it how do you gather the information
where do you do this well it's like
anything else one thing stands on the
shoulders of another so if I do research
and let us say oh oh colonial wars and
then I do research on the Revolutionary
War and then the 1812 and Mexico and the
Indians and so on it keeps building and
you keep the notes and you buy the books
I don't I buy everything I can because
then I have all the sources at my hand
so I have about four or five thousand
books almost all on military history
also on theology and religion because
that was my first interest I noticed
that some of the books until you've
written a soldier priest talks to youth
and you have one called ordained yeah
there are others here that have to do
with the
Church Catholic Church in America now a
study of the st. what's the source of
all by when did you write those why well
was I went to parochial schools and and
I went to pour them after the war but as
I said before I never liked the
classroom did you graduate from Fordham
yeah I went to Buffalo with the AP and
besides I I honestly never liked it very
frankly I'll tell you most of the time I
was kicked out of high school fairly
regularly and I ever get out of the
Passaic River with my dog and smoke
cigarettes and watch the young oil watch
traffic you know they don't like to hear
that because they but it's the truth
isn't it I'm telling the Mavericks
look at what she what's his name Robert
Roark do you remember him he went to I
think North Carolina all he did was stay
in his room and read novels and he did
very well yeah over the years have you
sold yourself a this is a Viking book
yes have you always written for Viking
no I began with Random House my editor
there was Bob Lewis and it was his first
book of my first book and it was a
helmet for my pillow and I just strong
went on and its thing about growing up
what about a family and then I doubled a
world Harper so many different ones and
then Viking is my this is my first book
with Viking yeah but they don't do much
military history and then what would you
what you told us what books did the best
which books did you enjoy the most
helmet for my billet pillow and strong
and on how long did it take you to write
this book this one yeah I'm not sure
what three months three months yeah it's
only 55,000 where is the other books and
don't forget I researched it in the wars
of America and strongmen on and as I say
these things stand on the shoulders and
you don't destroy your notes but when I
did let us say well were two that
delivered from evil that took between
two and three years was of America also
but I kept updating that so
could possibly be for three or four but
the point is if you're going to do a
subject you must master it and if you're
going to write fifty times a hundred
thousand you've got a mastery so it
really doesn't make that much difference
in the length of the research and if it
is in a particular field like military
history as I said before one book stands
on the shoulders of the other and this
is all almost exclusively American
military history except that one book
warfare which is a study of war and it's
a small book in the end there how many
copies of this book do you think will
sell I just want to say I would say in
hardcover it might sell as many as
30,000 it is big that's big oh yeah
yeah it is big it is big because books
this book is $25 and you know that means
for me the the senator contract is 10
percent of the retail price for the
first 5,000 copies 10 12 and a half
percent of retail price for the next
five out and then 15 percent for all
over 10,000 but you make more money in
the paperback if it's a mass paperback
no but as I said before I can still
drink first rose wine what is your in
European what's the secret to your
success and having 40 books I'm going to
tell you I came from a cultivated family
my father was a young ever tied in sales
promotion manager but Joseph Chris
Joseph Dickson crucible company I need
any more those famous pencils
Ticonderoga and so on and so forth he
was very proud that every year the AP
would put out a story something they
haven't ruined yet and always number one
was Ticonderoga number two he is dead of
course he would have loved that but he
was a very cultivated man and he had a
big library and it was dictionaries and
encyclopedias all over the house and
then it was an intellectual atmosphere
and you have a head start I dish based
sound sententious
who put on or affected but I always
wanted to be a writer since I can
remember
so I mean there was a blackboard in the
kitchen you know before I went to school
and things like that you know so that I
never I wanted to be a writer
until I realized and this sounds
pretentious that books were not the
works of nature or of God but of men and
women and then I was writing poetry
since I was 12 or 13 what's the
atmosphere and what you're right
preferably a black wall but it's the
best scenery for a writer better for an
artist but not for a blank wall yes
I mean you face a blank wall sure you I
have a lovely study but what's your
intimate I mean it doesn't make any
difference but the difficulty is
cranking up the Machine getting it
started you can sit there for hours
actually because if you go past that
where you're at an impasse you have to
go back to you have to go back to it and
every morning or afternoon whenever you
write you have to go up and shoot that
old bear onto your desk between the eye
that's right and you have to have
enormous discipline especially if you
like to drink I know so many good
writers we're down the drain if you'd
like to drink you can't do it it's a
reward should never be a crutch so what
time of day do you do it if it depended
didn't start but on my family and I
would always do it my wife would get up
early and feed them put most of school
and I would exercise play handball so in
the morning as I said to an exercise
with an E and an O stay in shape and to
exercise with a know the devil booths
but I would always start writing about
one until five or six now I only write
about one until three and do you write
longhand no typewriter and I I can't use
those dreadful so you see called word
processor still have that royal that
your wife gave you and oh yeah yeah but
uh it disappeared long ago because I did
a lot already but I wrote my first three
books on it
but I have four typewriters you know
they don't make em any no and I tried to
get the so called word processor and
when I write I put my hands on the
keyboard to think well what the hell it
- you sent something crazy and if you
have a power outage so you've got three
months in that thing
wow I'm serious so I decided no that's
not for me I'm not of this age I have
the finest mind of the thirteenth
century this is not my century I mean
people talk of the internet and so I
don't care about that kind of stuff how
do you like it when you go around and do
this kind of stuff
interviewing do you do you like to be
interviewed television interviews radio
interviews I mean what do you think of
that part of this well I I enjoy that
because it's a form of recognition and
I'd say I do enjoy it I love doing what
I'm doing and I always wanted to do it
it's wonderful I was a Keelung we had a
house do everything critic you up okay
we had a house Sanger for 13 years and
it was and QRS lovely it's beautiful and
it's not like like save Annabelle doats
Florida which is also beautiful but it's
manicured key wise natural beauty and so
on and so many of these retired
executive doctors lawyers and someone
that say to me you know you're really
lucky I said I know they said you have
something to do should all we can do it
play golf or bridge and drink you
shouldn't retire if you're healthy how
much longer do you intend to write books
well my mother lived to be 87 my father
lived to be 85 my brother John was 14
years older than me just died about a
couple of weeks ago he was 88 so and how
old are you now 75 74 I'll be 75 in
December are you working on your next
book yeah I'm doing a series of novels
for tour a branch of the st. Martin's
Press Americans at war he take him take
the fighting Flynn fire me through all
the wars I began this of more than 15
years ago for new American library but
then somebody was a higher up into
American Library I did three of them
gave an unknown and unpublished author
and advanced listen to this eight
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
the exodus from me nal as was called
with enormous and I just quit I had four
edit since on one book serve well it's
now owned by Viking and it's quite
different but I'm doing these for a
different outfit and and it's it's a
good change of pace you know I mean I
love to write but I look you can't turn
a phrase very well in fiction I mean in
fact but in the history you cannot turn
a phrase very well in fiction but in
fact in history you can't you know what
I mean you know yeah let's say somebody
like Churchill he was a woman came up to
him and he was a master of repartee you
know and when we came up to she said
Benson you're drunk
he said Bessie you're ugly but tomorrow
I shall be sober do you understand what
I mean you can do that in dialog maybe
but the turn of fiction like the thing I
read to you that in fiction cuz you know
what the editor was writing in the in
the margent purple prose of all that and
you've got a book here on George
Washington yeah and the saga at George
Washington's will of the revolution yeah
you got one on the American Civil War
you've got a book here on the saga World
War two on and on of all the people
you've written about yeah in the in the
last how many years old thirty forty
years fifty fifty years who do you
admire the most
well I in my analyst what did you like
me thing I mean I may not surprise you
but don't know why am I most as an
American just the a lot of people you
know worry this is a world that all the
people you've written about who you
would you like to have met that you like
Harry Truman among living presidents
that my son same here I also had my
George Washington I admired although he
was a prince Thomas Edison
thinking the things he did thinking
funny that he lighted the world movies
film everything so many things and he
was irascible this could be but so what
he achieved really James Madison the
author of our Constitution he was a
political genius it's always being
ascribed Thomas Jefferson but that just
isn't so it was Madison little guy huge
are you political yourself no no no no I
do not know I do not admire politicians
but I do admire politicians who become
statesmen they something happens in the
presidency that altered should alter a
man's attitude he is no longer a
political animal but that doesn't happen
too frequently have you met any of these
folks did you ever meet Harry Truman or
Dwight Eisenhower when Mitch Furman was
when I was a newspaperman in Buffalo
when he defeated to win he had that big
headline you know GOP wins White House
he's got a big grin on his face showing
it to the crowd forty-eight and he came
to Buffalo and I covered him he's on it
whistles stop you know I never met
anybody else I don't I don't seek the
company of politician we'll go back to
this book on Okinawa
the last battle World War two once a
while you get some glimpse in here what
you thought of the Japanese the Japanese
soldier was a very brave man don't let
anyone tell you differently but he was
very barely led he was also extremely
cruel you know the defect of the virtue
of bravery is often cruelty and I'll
give a reason I did I give you an
example about no Briton all right I give
an example on Guadalcanal the Japanese
captured a marine and they tied him to a
tree and they had their medical corpsman
there and they gave a lecture in
vivisection
devastation that's right and this comes
from the diary they were in better--it
Diaries
and the Japanese medic he said wrote in
the diary was the most interesting
lecture I ever attended and then on
Brett and I had a buddy named stinky
Davis I think that was his name and he
was a flanker as we marched from one
place to another that's a great jungle
layer and somehow they captured they
tied him to a tree - when we found him
he had 33 bayonet wounds in his body
plus his Marine tattoos stuffed in his
mouth followed by his pain inside but no
I do not admire them and all I think
there's savage and primitive and they
are just relatively savage in their
economic warfare as they were in the
irrilium military warfare and you know
record Jesus fellas John Keegan an
Englishman he wrote a summary of the
river in the London Times and you know
terrible and I'm sure you've seen it the
articles in the New York Times or The
Washington Post whatever of this phony
science they took a man and put him in a
huge your glass a capsule and cut him
vertically and wanted to see what made
him taken so on then we're going to
discuss they did discover that the
biological warfare could be used against
American city for the whole point is how
were they going to deliver you know why
they click on it but 7,000 miles of our
ocean what's their weakness what what in
your opinion is the Japanese weakness
wait this is it they're still tribal
it's still tribal they changed overnight
I I wrote in my book delivered from evil
a study of Japanese people and overnight
they changed from being tribal with the
samurai authorised to you know kill
anybody was doing anything different to
westernize it was almost comical they
were top hats frock coats and so on and
of course there's small people and was
almost comical they absolutely changed
from medical tribal people trying to be
Western
but I don't think down deep that they
change very much from the samurais they
merely changed the thought police one
last thing you write about ernie pyle in
this list and who was or any pile for
someone that has never heard of him
early pile was the most famous war
correspondent in world war ii and he was
the bravest and the most compassionate
and he never went behind the lines like
the great I am Ernest Hemingway
everybody now his writing World War two
my editor said you're going to put in
the Hemingway liberating Paris I said
I'd kill myself first because he never
liberated Paris I had the good sense to
listen to the ego and he had the French
liberate virus oh the showman Hemingway
would go out during the day in his Jeep
but go back to a hotel behind the lines
and drink brandy and tell stories and so
on Pyle was always with the truth it's a
shame that he couldn't have stayed
longer with the Marines
where was he killed yeah Shima where the
Japanese before it was overrun by us
hey downed American pilots and where's
yeh SEMA also kunal how far off 50 miles
something like that you devote in here
three different photos to the Ernie Pyle
story and there's a photo right here of
the actual burial yes yeah it was a
snipe and it won't know was a machine
gunner and he was with a a company
commander in a jeep and they went into a
ditch he lifted his head about this
service right above the wheel you know
and right between the forehead he wrote
a most moving story about the burial of
a captain he had a Polish name and an
army captain and the troops are really
the variable diverted devoted to it was
really great really great he was good
do you the best anybody in today's media
world would this soldiers beat if I
don't think so because um
for one thing world were tools told
everybody was so that the writings of
these correspondents were famous oh guy
with the AP he was good too huh Jesus I
did a book with them oh oh hey guy
it's a trouble I don't have Alzheimer's
because it's all aged but anyway his
name was Boyle Hal boy I'll boil he was
another of the great ones he was with AP
and he was much like pile in his habits
and he was very good and of course their
their reports and articles were in the
public press day of the day of the day
and there were famous but neither of
them boil or ernie pyle made home and
when pile o to was over in your pile
went to the pacific with a marine here's
to what the cover of the book looks like
the subject is okinawa the last battle
of world war ii and our guest has been
Robert Leckie thank you very much thank
you